we're gonna dive head first into the
shallow end with this next story about
Eliza blue Chrissy Mayer and all the
stuff that's been gone over the past
week and uh we'll just uh we'll be as
candid as possible I'm sure we'll piss
some people off but we have this tweet
from Chrissy mayor for those that aren't
familiar Chrissy Mayer is a comedian and
she hosts a podcast called simpcast and
she's been on the show I think I think a
couple times right it's been a couple
times we've had on the show before and
so there's been some controversy related
to a guest we had recently Eliza blue
and some censorship actions that she's
been accused of notably filing privacy
requests against people who talk about
her past work and so here we have the
story from Chrissy Mayer she says Eliza
blue got four of my YouTube videos
removed for showing a fair and balanced
dock trailer which featured three to
five seconds of her public at the time
now removed World Star Hip-Hop video
must be nice to have the power to
rewrite history then Gaslight Twitter
and YouTube into accepting it
now I'll say is that right
um you know I said previously I'm
uninterested in this and I'll kind of
you know I think this is this got to the
point where literally right before the
show I saw this tweet and I'm like okay
okay guys you got me all right like I'm
starting to see and learn more that's
having me question what that what what's
going on if YouTube videos getting
pulled and we're hearing that a bunch of
people actually had YouTube videos
getting pulled and so this clearly is an
abuse of the system to a degree that
we've not seen for a while now it used
to be in the early days of YouTube there
were attempts by political Rivals to to
falsely flag and get people's content
removed and now it seems like we're
seeing an uptick in this particularly
pertaining to Eliza Bloom the first
thing I'll say is as it pertains to the
issues related to me personally you know
look man
um I say it a million times I'm I'm an
arrogant and so don't don't
come at me and yell at me and scream in
my face and think I'm gonna bend the
knee and do anything for you and I will
tell everybody right off the bat we had
this person on the show that I don't
care too much about I don't I don't
follow her career I don't know much
about her I don't handle booking without
the show two times but all of a sudden
we found ourselves inundated with and
I'm not saying you guys got to be very
careful because when I said that there
was a PR firm running like 50 accounts
everyone started claiming I called
literally the millions of people who are
watching these videos but I never said
that yeah but we started we we got some
very gruesome
um Christmas may not the right word but
let's just say you know people cross the
line with what they were sending to us
and um the images they were posting of
people easiest way to get me to be like
I will I will not give you what you want
but here's here's what I have to say
about this there are a lot of people who
are genuinely concerned about what we're
seeing in terms of what Eliza Blue's
done and her past work and there's a big
difference between those people and the
very few people I am directly
criticizing the people who are posting
just really awful photos and videos
sending awful things to us and I want to
make sure that people understand because
there's still this this you know here's
what I said earlier
following the project Veritas stuff
following you know obviously the Crowder
daily wire stuff following these
Republicans getting shot
I'm reading this I get I have a source
contacting me they say we want you to
read this letter check this out and I'm
like okay well we're going to publish
this and I'm reading this and I'm like
yo if if all of this bad stuff is
happening right now to various
organizations and everyone's fighting
with each other yeah that that's it like
infiltrate destroy right you you make me
divide and conquer yeah I'm not going to
be all about that right so I'm I set out
right to to Jeremy Hamley of the
quartering look I apologize I don't want
to be fighting with you we agree on way
too much for me to be bickering or
complaining about something that is like
one issue where you know ultimately
probably agree mostly on it but there's
like a personal issue that's making you
know me upset or something like that
when I'm looking at we have another
story we'll talk about in a minute a
woman saying that she used to uh work in
in gender affirmation for children and
now she's realizing how bad it is I'm
like there's a lot more things that we
all agree on that we need to be focused
on my biggest concern with all of this
is
obviously censorship is bad but if I'm
gonna get distracted and and and you
know personally aggrieved or whatever
and that means infighting will erupt
that takes us off mission
we're being played we're being played
and so I'll say this to you right now
when I came out with my video earlier
and said exactly that like Jeremy we I
shouldn't be fighting with you I
shouldn't be com I should like that
that's not that's not what we should be
doing that's not what I should be doing
uh I so I apologize Jeremy put out a
video saying he apologizes I have
tremendous respect for that and I
sincerely apologize there are still
people trying to drum up this infighting
and and that is exactly what I'm talking
about when all this starts and I'm this
guy who's sitting here like look man I
don't know anything about her some we
booked her on the show because she's on
Twitter and she's a prominent activist I
didn't know that people had beef with
her and I don't know what that beef is
we get people sending us
let me just say like videos that
video photos and videos that I just
think are would would make a dad you
know like if a dad found out people were
doing about that his daughter he'd end
up in jail that kind of stuff yeah so
you wanna you wanna come at me and my
friends with these really horrifying
things and I'm gonna be like outright
not not getting anywhere near this but I
I genuinely and legitimately understand
that's not most people so I hope all of
you understand that there are people
still right now trying to get us to keep
fighting I'm not going to do it I will
outright say especially upon seeing
Chrissy Mayer get get her videos taken
down I'm I'm absolutely wrong about that
I I I was personally slighted and that
put blinders on me I don't want to fight
with anybody I will keep being an
arrogant and I will say that
but I also recognize we shouldn't be
fighting if we can avoid it and we can
focus on things that are more important
so the only thing I didn't say just one
last thought is please keep an eye out
for those who are still in the chat
right now desperately trying to get me
to get angry and to fight with you guys
when I'm saying no wait man like we need
to come together on this yeah I think
the big thing here is people like they
say in soccer if you're a Defender keep
your eye on the ball and I think so many
people got their eye off the ball in
this story and I'm like you pointed out
with the censorship with the I mean I
don't know if you point out the legal
action she threatened supposedly online
I think those are things they're worthy
derision and worthy of looking into and
see what is going on here why is this
happening maybe there's more to the
story but this thing got taken so out of
control into such a level to things that
had nothing to do with it her past which
took me wrong like sure that like maybe
like discredited her or something but
that I don't personally myself I
couldn't care if she made up all of that
that's not pertinent information to me
the what is pertinent to me is did she
threaten legal action against people and
is she getting accounts taken down I
don't know I'm open to it seems that way
it seems to imply I read Shane's latest
article it seems there's something
building there maybe some sort of
argument I don't know I'm still open to
and the people criticizing Tim cast for
not jumping in already they literally
had a guy there and like it was clearly
not a fleshed out story so why would you
comment on something before it's a
fleshed out story but here's here's what
I think too and I can't speak for Shane
right I will I will tell you guys with
100 sincere honesty
I told Shane I don't think the story was
worth it I don't I don't know anything
about it and I said to him if you do
this you need to sit down with Jeremy
Hambly and we need to do like two
different profiles of like what is the
big picture here
's the problem
and uh we got baited because the things
that were sent to Shane I guarantee you
like and again I can't speak from saki
said this to me but I do know that
people posted very inappropriate things
about his family
you do that you guarant that's bait they
were trying to get us to fight and so
I've nowad people saying like bro it's
an OP like they're trying to make you
fight each other what I was saying is
it's a PR firm that I think was trying
to promote uh Eliza because it worked in
making her famous having John Rich come
on here and be like who is the lies I'm
hearing about now and I'm like man
that's so convenient for her and I'm
specifically referring to obviously not
like a YouTube channel where they're
talking about it I'm referring to the
people even still right now in the chat
who are desperately trying to make us
fight and they're the same accounts that
spam the same things over and over and
over again clearly inorganic desperately
trying to make conflict happen sometimes
even real people get caught in that
state of mind because it's like
scratching an itch it feels so good but
if you keep scratching you're going to
rip the skin off and make it bleed like
we're in the it feels really good situ
state right now don't keep scratching uh
you know Brittany venti got her got
videos taken down of her today I made a
YouTube video for the first time in
about a month and a half today about
this on my YouTube channel Ian Crossland
please check it out after the show and
I'll remind you again and I posted a
link to Brittany's video in that video
she showed clips from this world star
music video in question this is all
revolving around this one video I think
uh that had been previously taken down
but Britney still had clips from this
now removed video on her Channel then
that video was removed over the course
of the last six hours Eliza I'm
concerned that shame is a very powerful
dangerous feeling and if you are pushed
into becoming a useful tool for cancel
culture to hyperinflate cancel culture
because of your your I know it's generic
afraid of your past but just it it it's
don't become the villain that you're
looking to
squash out that's the best advice I
think I can give you right now
um but if these bands are unjust they
need to be rectified if something
Brittany said in her video she's showing
screenshots of Twitter's band thing and
they said that it was Private privately
privately created or distributed
sensitive content as a Twitter role it
was publicly distributed sensitive
content it was not private and it was
taken down for it being a privately
sensitive piece of content but how
sensitive is it really it was the music
video yeah she made the video she she
was proud of it she was you know uh
ostensibly she was was spreading it
around back in the day so I think that's
Up For Debate but I think it for the
sake of argument we'd say it is it is
sensitive content but it was public
sensitive content so Twitter reinstate
Brittany that ban is unjust in my
opinion simply put in just to go back to
like our position on this I think I got
tricked I think I think we all got
tricked here into taking out our anger
on people like Jeremy and Brittany I
think so I was like uh I don't want to
get into too much detail about what was
happening to us but like
you know these are my friends and people
I care about and I don't want to call
them threats or anything but the stuff
we were getting sent was let's just put
like put it triggering if someone sent
you the stuff that we got sent you'd
probably react the same way and then
when you know I was looking at I I made
this joke tweet earlier I was like daily
wire project Veritas me and the
quartering it's all you thought it was a
coincidence wait till phase two or
whatever like as a joke people thought
it was real and then I stopped and kind
of thought about it when I was reading
the Veritas letter and I'm like people
were saying is it a coincidence that
right after the Pfizer thing comes out
you know we have the Grammys brought to
you by Pfizer we do this big thing
complaining about it all of a sudden
we're getting slammed with these people
claiming to represent a group of people
but they're sending us some of the most
abhorrent and awful things you can
imagine pissing us off and making us
fight and then I'm just like yo nah I'm
not doing it you're not you you got me
you you got me for a few days but I'm
not gonna do it now and to some of the
nicest people I've ever met the two
people in question I've I've interact
with them met one of them personally and
like even with the limit time that
genuinely are some of the nicest people
ever who are you talking about uh the
one person because I'm sure we don't
want to name name the name to deflate it
no oh I don't care then and then Shane
Cashman so uh Shane met I've only met
him online uh done one show with him he
came on my show for Pony boys which is a
joking ripoff of Four Horsemen uh
because we're buddies and so who cares
uh but yeah I found my show he's like
the nice guy ever met and super
interesting fella and just for this to
happen to someone like that now that it
makes it better who they are but it's
just disgusting this is this is the
thing too it's like
even before we did anything we were
getting sent awful stuff and getting
attacked and then so I was like okay
well we're going to cover this and then
it ramped up and got crazier and then of
course I'm like I got an internal
conversation with Shane and I'm saying
like I don't know if we can handle
whatever though this is or what they're
doing and he's like oh we got to tell
the story man you know it's something I
really I I recommended well so I mean
Shane's clearly pissed I don't know I
think we talked to him the plan now is
maybe as soon as possible is to have
Chrissy Mayer on with Shane and then
just hash all this stuff out because I
think we're being played I love that
Britney ventian lies on at some point in
the future after we work through these
Cycles I think it's fantastic this is
this is this kind of thing we can avoid
in the future if we talk about it now
you know I realized we have a
responsibility to talk about this stuff
it's not stuff I want to do I don't want
to get dramatic and talk about my
friends online I don't know who did what
who said what but when it comes to
Banning and people losing their
livelihoods like if someone's banned
from Twitter that's their that could be
their life their their income and it's
are this show Tim me we we have a
responsibility to talk about cancel
culture and social media censorship I
don't it's it's just like you know with
great power comes great responsibility
and you have to make personal sacrifices
the sacrifice you have to make with talk
about this stuff
I think that it's pretty clear that I
don't imagine that people thought that
the the Tim cast brand was
pro-censorship uh because of this stuff
um but I mean there's a lot of people in
the chat that are like you said that are
still looking to Stir It Up that are
that are you know a lot of issues so
like that was that was the thing about
it is I'm seeing people post videos
being like you know I'm canceling my
membership at timcast.com and stuff like
that and we gained over a thousand
members in the past in the past week
which is three times like what we
normally do I think everybody involved
in this has become more famous as a
result of this whole thing no I think
you could call it infighting Stephen
Crowder is way more popular than he was
two months ago thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time